[Music]
Memorial then national holiday to
celebrate those who have died in service
so thank you for those bad for
Pendergrass Memorial Day
my favorite thing about it with the
Marchman question is everybody was just
at a time on that they get on Memorial
Day but reality are we should be taking
the time to kind of think about people
that have wasn't a lot of work and
sacrifice into getting us the life that
we have today
I think Memorial Day is a good day to
think about people or grandparents
certain military that's kind of stuff I
think about Memorial Day so you'll find
me at the barbecue for sir wherever
there's a grill I will bring me and
click on it you know that's my way of
celebrating is getting together taking
that David Lyfe station and good food
and bills to be hanging up giving big
those people so the makeup freedom to do
what we just may learn like my grandpa
was in the 2nd Armored Division in World
War two in the European theater and then
my other grandfather was stateside doing
maintenance and working on planes a lot
of my family's been ruling or Air Force
my grandfather's can mix what I have it
is the main ship the battleship
interesting story my grandfather was
drafted in World War two after he was
thirty within a month the law was passed
but no one over 30 would be transited my
other grandfather on the Pacific was in
an infinite of the army when he came
back after the war he worked at a TV
station and then worked for the space
program inclination so that's been cool
do you have any Emily memorial did in
World War one
my mom's great-uncle he was a Doughboy
and his guest on the front lines and he
came back and he kind of lost his mental
capacity and you know dealt with all
sorts of diseases and passed away you
know share the stories of those people
and remember them I think there's
there's Honor than that you know doing
the freedom that they gave us I mean we
do it every day look at this you have
the freedom to sit around making YouTube
videos every day we don't have to like
work in mind you watching what we got
you you even hear me say gun really yeah
Sid the n-word
[Music]
you
[Music]